Instagram today is really hard the only
way you hack it is the stuff I talk
about best practices of the moment why
am I doing a meme and then a video
constantly over the last 60 days on
Instagram why am I doing a two poost
Carousel first one is a meme and the
second one is the video you were
accustomed to seeing me just post a
video why am I doing that I promise you
it's not for kicks and Giggles it's what
is now working of this moment that can
give you the most upside it's like if
you're the best player in your six grade
football team that's good but when you
get to high school it gets harder to be
the best player and then there's college
and then there's the pros Instagram now
is the pros if you're going to really go
crazy you got to be the best